I'm excited for you that you get to see
this again crank up the volume for the
biggest event of the summer oh come on
Guardians laugh out loud funny exactly
you idiots oh no the perfect conclusion
of the Guardians Trilogy it's good to
have friends it's the best Marvel
movie since end game so that happens
Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie. Marvel released a bunch more Guardians
of the Galaxy 3 trailer footage which includes
the first appearance of Quasar from the comics
and the first F-bomb in a Marvel movie so I'll
explain what's going on they also said that
that F-bomb is going to be uncensored in the
theatrical cut when you go see it in the theaters
they also just revealed more of the Guardians 3000
team starhawks original Guardians of the Galaxy
team so if you're brand new to the channel we're
doing a giveaway for Guardians of the Galaxy 3
IMAX tickets all you have to do to enter is just
be a subscriber and post your favorite moment
from the trailer so far on the video but the
real big thing here is the Quasar character a lot
of people wondering when they're gonna do Quasar
it was revealed that this girl in the trailer
that the high evolutionary is experimenting
on is actually Phyla-Vell now there's a bunch of
versions of Quasar in the comics just like Captain
Marvel just like Nova like a lot of space-based
characters pass the mantle down a couple different
times but Phyla-Vell was important because she
was Quasar during the annihilation Conquest
storyline which is where this modern version
of the Guardians of the Galaxy teen that we see
in the MCU came together for the first time she
also joined the Guardians of the Galaxy team in
a later roster just like Adam Warlock who was
also in that Annihilation Conquest storyline
working with the Guardians the uniforms you see
the Guardians wearing in the trailer are also the
same uniforms that they wore in that Annihilation
Conquest storyline so the movie just in general
is barring a lot of Easter eggs and references
from that Annihilation Conquest storyline the
other big connection too like we just got the
Marvel's trailer Captain Marvel 2 with all those
characters in a different part of space this
is like Marvel's other space-based franchise
Phyla-Vell is also meant to be the daughter of
the original Captain Marvel Marvel so there's
a connection to the Marvels through her character
but as of me posting this video I haven't seen the
movie so I don't know if they're going to be any
cameos from the Marvel's characters in this movie
the big difference with her character in this
movie is that she's obviously much younger and
during that Annihilation story she had already
become Quasar taking the quantum bands usually
you don't take the mantle of Quasar until you're
given the quantum bands another big connection to
the Marvel's movie through the Bangles and the
quantum bands they're meant to be relatively
similar they've been all these theories about
Miss Marvel's Bangles like where is the other
Bangle turns out that it's being worn by Dar Benn
who's the main villain of the movie and they just
revealed in the trailer that they're basically
the MCU version of the Kree Nega bands they're
kind of like Green Lanterns Rings they can create
constructs with them which is how Ms Marvel can
use them with her powers now she's also a mutant
in the MCU like we're talking about X-Men Easter
eggs here so there's like something on top of
that the difference between the quantum bands
of Quasar and the kree Nega bands are that the
quantum bands draw their power from the quantum
Zone which is like an alternate dimension in
the Korean Nega bands draw their power from the
Negative Zone thus the name Nega bands it gets
a little confusing in the comics if you haven't
been reading them for a long time but in the MCU
they tend to simplify all those things so don't
worry too much about the particulars there and
in the trailer it doesn't look like Phyla-Vell
has the quantum bands yet anyway during the movie
it seems like she hasn't gotten her full origin
story yet and either she was created by the high
evolutionary inside the MCU like she's one of his
experiments in creating the perfect life form
or he captured one of Marvel's Offspring and
used them to create phylabel in the comics she
was actually the bioengineered super weapon just
this perfect being patterned after genus fell
the actual biological child of the original
Captain Marvel Marvel and Elysium his wife she
was an artificially created Eternal from the same
Planet Titan that Thanos came from she was meant
to be the same type of Eternal that Thanos was
their son genis-vell became so powerful as the
next version of Captain Marvel he was a kree
Eternal hybrid basically making him super powerful
naturally in addition to all the extra powers that
he had as a new version of Captain Marvel his
mother Elysium decided to create another female
copy of him calling her Phyla-Vell and their names
are meant to be references to genus and phylum. She
has a bunch of different space-based Adventures
it gets really complicated in the comics like her
backstory the continuity is a little complicated
they tried to to stream like that in more modern
Comics she tries to fight her brother Genis-Vell
for the right to become the next Captain Marvel
but then goes off to have her own Adventures she
becomes the new version of Quasar which is what
she's been for the most part in the comics then
she goes on to have adventures with the Guardians
of the Galaxy just because she's half kree and
half Eternal she has this highly evolved body like
she was designed biologically to be the superior
being she can absorb and redirect energy she has
a low level Cosmic awareness and after she gets
the quantum bands and becomes Quasar she becomes
super powerful most the time in the artwork that
depicts her that you see popping up all over the
place she's wielding the Oblivion sword too which
is an extra huge power-up she gains through her
different Adventures she also has a long time
connection to the moon dragon character who is
drax's daughter in the MCU even though they
haven't done Moondragon Inside the MCU yet
I think we'll learn more about drax's backstory
during this movie though in the comics Moondragon
eventually also does work with the Guardians of
the Galaxy when she gets older but like I said
in the movie it just seems like they're saying
that the high evolutionary created Phyla-Vell in
his attempts to create the perfect life form like
that's his whole thing is trying to create the
perfect life that's why he has all these human
animal hybrids on this version of counter Earth
he's trying to create the perfect version of life
just in general life forms and the way that they
live even though everything has that funny 80s
shine to it like everything looks like it's stuck
at a time in the 80s with these weird animal human
hybrids I think what James Gunn is saying with the
Phyla-Vell characters that potentially she could
become part of a future guardian's roster just
like Adam Warlock could become part of the next
version of the Guardians of the Galaxy because
even though they probably won't do Guardians of
the Galaxy 4 as a movie the team will come back
with a different roster in future movies and we
get a much longer version of that funny scene of
them trying to drive the car Peter Quill not being
able to because he doesn't know how to drive he
left earth when he was eight years old in nebula
not being able to open the door because she's from
outer space like she hasn't actually experienced
cards or technology like this before but if you're
a child of this era like if you grew up during
the 80s with cars that work kind of like this
you instantly recognize a scene like this like
it feels like a family trying to get in a car
arguing with each other just get in the freaking
car speaking of other Guardians of the Galaxy
rosters we see the rest of the Guardians 3000
team remember they're all technically ravagers
in the MCU so they're all on the same team but
the ravagers organization itself is kind of like
a loose collection of different factions in Star
Hawks team Sylvester Stallone's character just
happens to be made up of the original Guardians
3000 team from the comics yondu's original team
so all the characters from that team and Guardians
of the Galaxy 2 are back for this scene with a few
exceptions like Michelle Yeoh's Aleta ogord she
was starhawk's white but obviously now she's in
changed martinex's face so that it looks a little
bit more like Michael Rosenbaum in real life if
you couldn't tell in the first movie that was
Michael Rosenbaum Krugarr is back he performs
a similar more magic trick to emote like he did
in the second movie he's a sorcerer just like
Doctor Strange they wield the exact same type
of magical energy which is why the color is the
same there's many different types of magic in the
MCU that's why different Magic based characters
have different colors of magic like Loki uses
a different type of magic than Doctor Strange
that's why his is green as the Scarlet Witch who
wields chaos magic that's why her magic is red in
the same with hack of the Harkness who wields
a different kind of magic which is why hers is
purple I love the way they have the Mainframe
character here just floating next to Martinex
Laughing with him if you don't remember from
the second movie that was voiced by Miley Cyrus
who sounds like she might be back for this movie
too just because it's a really quick Cameo Scene
It seems like they also reveal that nebula has
wings during the movie like she's gone full-on
battle angel with her new arm as well James Gunn
also revealed that rocket is the person who gave
her her new arm probably is a thank you for giving
him winter soldier's arm for Christmas the other
big thing too James Gunn just revealed is that the
voice of Lyla the otter Rocket's girlfriend from
the comics who's also from the same same place
he's from is actually Linda Cardellini who also
plays Hawkeye's wife in the other MCU movies
in the Hawkeye series Laura Barton who they
also recently revealed is the Mockingbird of the
MC youth that's what the whole subplot with the
watch was about during the Hawkeye series she is
Agent 19 who is the Mockingbird character meaning
that at some point she was also part of shield and
that's how she got to know Hawkeye but if you're
a long time James Gunn fan you may remember that
James Gunn wrote the Scooby-Doo movie she played
Velma in those original Scooby-Doo movies so
that's the James Gunn connection there we think
this is a brainwashing facility for an evil cult
well maybe this is the secret Relic thingy day
worship she was coming back mostly because of
that not because she had been in the other MCU
stuff as Hawkeye's wife the other weird thing too
is if you've been watching a lot of the press is
that you may have seen the Kumail nanjiani was at
the premiere with James Gunn and everyone else I
don't know if that means that Kingo has a cameo
in the movie like are they doing eternals cameos
in the movie The Last we saw of Kingo in the MCU
were during the Guardians of the Galaxy holiday
special for a couple Christmas movies that he
had made that were being released but before the
events of that he'd actually been taken from Earth
with the other eternals by ayersham the judge to
judge whether or not Earth was worthy to continue
existing I'm not expecting a ton of Eternal stuff
maybe there's a couple Easter eggs about stuff
that's going on in different parts of the Galaxy
though the way James Gunn talks about the movie
Mostly it's localized to just these characters
and wrapping up all their storylines which is why
he's teasing so many other characters that were
part of the Guardians of the Galaxy in different
rosters like oh there are some characters in
this movie that could wind up replacing some of
these characters that are leaving or being killed
off let me know in the comments too if you think
any of the characters will die during the events
of the movie I don't think they're going to kill
everyone off I think that some people will survive
and continue on there's a bunch of other big
trailers that are dropping this week so make sure
you enable alerts for my channel so you don't miss
any of those everyone click here for my brand new
Fantastic Four atom driver video and click here
for my brand new Deadpool 3 Wolverine in X-Force
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!